okay what are you guys working right now
what's going on
so the preliminary details of this crash
you see behind me are as followed at
approximately 6 a.m the nevada state
police responded to a two-vehicle crash
possibly a fatality at the location of
ir 215 westbound at valley verde
upon arrival it was determined that a
light a blue jeep was traveling
westbound in the middle traveling
when a black sports bike approached at a
high rate of speed
the black sports bike did go ahead on
with the rear of the blue jeep causing
the jeep to then strike the center
median and then was redirected across
all the travel lanes
the rider of the bike was ejected on
impact and was transported to sunrise
trauma in critical condition
unfortunately we were notified that the
rider of the bike was pronounced
deceased at sunrise trauma
we current
we currently have a hard closure in
place
on ir 215 westbound and everybody's
being diverted off at valley verde we
anticipate this hard closure being in
place for at least approximately maybe
another two hours so we highly encourage
the public to please take surface
streets if possible or take surface
streets at least to valle verde and then
you can jump back onto the 215 westbound
from there
any signs of alcohol
impairment is unknown at this time with
the rider we'll know that later in the
investigation so this might just be like
a morning traffic just accidentally
um no we we did have witnesses tell us
that the rider was traveling at a high
rate of speed
so speed is definitely a factor in this
other safety tips you want to crash to
the public yes please slow down we
appreciate their patience this morning
while we conduct this investigation this
is someone's loved one and we appreciate
them letting us put time and effort into
this investigation
please you know just make alternate
routes to and from your destination
where you're going right now we don't
want to see anybody get involved in road
rage we understand they're backed up the
traffic's backed up and people are
getting frustrated but we just
appreciate their patience and while we
conduct our investigation so please put
down the phones pay full attention so
there's no further
crashes
resulted from this incident
the driver of the jeep is good stable
condition minor injuries we do not
suspect impairment and that is also a
male adult